yeah i'm playing haga again with black
and they've got this have to face one be
three again in the millionth game
probably yeah here switch to an I'm c4
based approach against me after I've
played Bishop b5 before a couple of
times and got good positions is a
position where white might be able to
play g4 I don't see maybe 95 also might
be a move to be perfectly honest yes
going with Jeff oh yeah yeah that might
be a move absolutely so okay not much
choice this will be pure chaos of course
yeah okay this is this I didn't didn't
really fear so much i was thinking
Bishop f5 and i'm pretty sure that this
should give me some kind of compensation
anyway i have to play the move and so
don't have any any alternative anyway ok
so if or what do i do night f4 is a move
okay place this okay i can take just go
back to f6 the normal kind of move i
also have night before you of course
that probably wins the Queen like night
before a be night be Bishop f4 Knight to
Bishop situation that wins the Queen but
I don't know how convincing that is
some strong strong doubts
okay I can take and play Knight f6 like
the simple solution not sure it works
but it definitely looks very dangerous
for me and yeah but night before doesn't
work right takes 90 expression he's got
three pieces and and a big attacker that
I that won't work what else what else
are you was not working okay i guess i
have to take it play Knight f6
yeah maybe I should have just done that
a lot quicker I mean this is the line I
can be considered immediately and I
didn't see how he wins so probably I
should have just played that even though
this is clearly dangerous for black I
mean that's absolutely absolutely an
absolutely clear yeah g6 don't doesn't
work the only I mean if you form maybe I
think I have to go here
now it's not so easy for why these two
to get every piece involved if you
castles long i'll just i'll take a three
and the night f6 is my key defender as
long as this is there it'sit's kind of
it should be it should be ok ok now I
can take him Queen takes that screen g5
so the night has to capture now then I
just take the form ok but now need to
clean takes up on things I think Queen
takes don't castles I have to give to
I'm covering h6 that was one idea that
the queen is covering the h6 pawn for
possible tactics on that ok he he
canceled yeah no big alternative i think
i also have to be ready to take be too
with the check can check on c5 it's not
not winning though I can just trade
stuff I know
I have to be quicker this is the biggest
problem the time I think the position is
now probably winning for black or
clearly better at least yeah so you see
threatening to take this time morning
probably isn't in 95 95 right by one of
95 taking taking too long for those easy
moves 24 there is now yeah there's 93 m
it did this work I've got 41 games
against the sky with a plus 18 score
check
no it should we know white resigns yeah
Reggie form this is this is a very very
tough tough position then yeah this is
also something that has to be checked
but I don't think it works i can take
here it's an important check tactic that
I have to check here yeah but he went
for g4 which is really interesting yeah
and now d phi i have to go Bishop f5 I
guess not sure not sure maybe you
forward yeah this move I thought I can
probably take him and just go for a
counter-attack yeah I mean I didn't
calculate it as possible this is this
and now locally 89 f for those kind of
things at the engine actually gives me a
full win here it's still a a completely
murky position check and again I've got
this and Queenie to made a thread it
seems there is no attack just minor
three yeah tough okay Bishop d3 take
stakes and now Knight f6 here um this
this looks interesting but I don't think
it's good check this is what I was was
calculating it here um yeah this is a
weird position White has three minor
pieces for the Queen and I've got two
extra points 6 against for bit the
position you know is very difficult to
play I mean I probably have to go h6 and
now something like this now it looks
downright terrible early those three
minor pieces they're all get towards my
king I mean it's highly technical that
it doesn't look doesn't a bride so this
Knight f6 looks okay yeah and now tons
of
sibilities he played 95 right oops this
is the most obvious looking over there
are this 94 for example night h form the
computer funny enough as usual gives 000
right here I'm winning like minus 3 or
something and 95 was an interesting
movie s already haha no didn't see that
that's a new glow tactic Jack White is
totally uncoordinated home okay this is
also should win the rookie eight is good
i hope this also wins yeah it should it
should now yeah 95 is just check it's
just came over check wins wins
everything and here he only has one
check and i'm coming first with my
meeting mailing attack tough tough game
okay thanks for watching